oh brother
it's still a mystery
won't you heal we felt it was important
to have a moment of silence after the
film it's just so that way you can have
a means to process what you just saw I
felt like maybe 30 to 45 seconds of just
a voice and since we had actual singers
from the Detroit movie the actual
dramatics in the film I mean I feel like
with any song you should have a kind of
a Shakespeare Tale like it starts off
with an establishment and a rising
action a climax
falling action in the end except for
this particular song we probably did it
three times and doing the actual music
there are a lot of challenges to do we
have to do the musical version of
document 95 it's a kind of a film 8
filmmakers challenge where you given all
these restrictions for us the audio
version of that was not using any modern
plugins
in the beginning you can hear my foot
tapping the floorboard
that's my not too Michael Jackson when
you read Michael Jackson's credits
you'll see all these unorthodox
instruments like my bathroom floor
stopping board let speak up if heaven
beyond together you have a floor
stomping board for the bathroom so here
my foot there's or not to him I told my
dad that they have to get me a character
like in 1967 none of us have Juilliard
level musician ship vocabulary we had to
play like amateurs which is right up my
alley because hip hop samples for a
while his records
River mics that we used are very very
sensitive we had to place soft when
Tariq's part comes in it took everything
I mean to not leave my wrists like
literally I'm playing with little wrist
action like coming I'm hitting the drums
with my thumb my index fingers like
that's how soft I was playing
we've never recorded a song while facing
each other and playing at the same time
so imagine a collective of 17 people
playing at their softest a song that
sounds intense it sounds like you know
literally destroying the drums but I'm
not like I'm barely moving any parts of
my arms when I'm playing this and I
wanted to sound like Superman just comes
in and busts through the wall like that
sort of thing initially I thought I was
just gonna play a rhythm I felt like
that would it did disservice to the song
so I was like well let me not play any
rhythm like let me just do a drum solo
over his rapping so I was trying to
convey what a riot would sound like
I know that Bulow was concerned about
the cracks in his voice on the second
verse bruised and scarred and fear er
and we ain't scare y'all his voice is
cracking he wanted to perfect it and I
was like No
so you sure you want me I was just
messing around I was a lot of a lot of
times the first take or practice take
sometimes I'll have it roll the tape and
let's rehearse it guys and then I keep
that cuz you're not overthinking what
you're doing you just naturally go along
to reach technical timing is one of the
most precise meticulous quantized
deliveries in hip-hop he's doing that
without inhaling once so going to
preacher mode like I need you to growl I
need you to scream
you know I'm if allows a performance
artist and a jazz musician and all these
things
he totally he uses all of his emotions
all of his feelings and it comes out in
the performance
it's all kathryn bigelow bet yes so it's
not gonna be a sweet spiritual kind of a
change is gonna come three minute very
sweet gospel we comfort feet I told her
it's going to be a hard pill to swallow
and more than anything this is probably
going to be therapy for the roots than
anything to get what we just saw once
green out so to start from silence to to
a growing action to rage back to silence
to pondering to confusion to sadness
then more rage it was hard to do but you
know we're up to the challenge
you